no one needs
[Music]
[Laughter]
help
yo ho welcome to a pirate's life nobody
expected pirates of the caribbean curse
of the black pearl to be as big of a hit
as it was the film led to four highly
successful sequels johnny depp became
one of the biggest stars in hollywood
playing jack sparrow and revitalized the
modern day blockbuster today we're
setting sail and finding out what
exactly went into making the pirates of
the caribbean curse of the black pearl
so i'd be having that dress back before
you go
the scene which finds kira knightley's
elizabeth swann walking the plank took
two days to film nightly recalls being
terrified but when the crew told her
they could use a stunt double for when
her character jumps off the plank she
responded by saying i was like i've been
standing up here for two days do you
really think that i'm not gonna jump off
this thing
among one of the many reasons why johnny
depp was cast in the role of captain
jack sparrow was that the studio felt
that he already had the vibe of a modern
day pirate in order to retain a look
that was still in touch with the film
setting the makeup artist had to get
creative when covering depp's personal
tattoos so they used such smears and
costumes to cover several of his tattoos
and would proceed to add new pirate
themed ones depp did keep one of his
pirate tattoos which was jack sparrow's
own name which stepped kept to both
honor the character as well as his son
who was born the year before the release
of the film
the code is more what you call
guidelines than actual rules
welcome aboard the black pearl joffrey
rush was so committed to mastering the
art of sword fighting that the crew
became sick of dealing with him depp was
also committed to the craft and
developed jack sparrow's flamboyant
fighting style which was inspired by the
famous muhammad ali his method involved
keeping his arms down and letting his
opponent come to him
several contact lenses were made to help
show off mackenzie crook's riggetti's
wooden eye with a hard lens used to make
his eye bulge even more lee ornenberg's
pintel also had contact lenses that were
used to make his eyes look extremely
yellow joffrey rush had contact lenses
that made his eye colors less bright and
more dull so he'd appear more sickly as
barbosa even johnny depp had contact
lenses that doubled as sunglasses that
would help him not squint during long
days of filming in the sun hey it's
clean it's not supposed to be clean the
curse of the black pearl already had
quite the elaborate wardrobe and prop
department the process of casting jack
sparrow's fellow pirate and prisoner
extras was definitely a unique process
the process involved bringing in around
600 bikers and out-of-work actors into a
basement at disney and giving them real
weapons to work with after people
started getting hurt they switched to
rubber ones on top of that there were
900 wardrobe pieces in total the clothes
from the film initially arrived clean
and put together it wasn't actually
until the costume design team had to
work hard to make the clothes appear far
dirtier than they originally were the
cave set is one of the largest sets
built on a stage in hollywood
one of the film's biggest and most
extravagant sets is the treasure cave in
the film's third act this set alone took
well over five months to build with 100
craftsmen working to make the set look
as good as possible i almost have a dot
to not see those dots
nearly 50 makeup artists worked on the
film often teeming with some of the
hairstylist the film's makeup process of
grunging up each actor was also a
different process that required the team
to apply the makeup and prosthetics in
layers and was stippled on each cast
member with a brush instead of a sponge
there were days on set where up to 30 or
40 hairdressers would work on the film's
large ensemble of principal actors as
well as the extras the hairdressers
would have to work on every single cast
member from the townsfolk to the british
guard to of course the pirates
themselves it was like an assembly line
process with all the cast having to take
a seat that was open in either the
makeup corner or the hair stylist corner
but that's a gamble of llamas
there's never a guarantee of coming back
obviously a pirate really isn't a pirate
without rotting teeth the teeth were
mainly just colors which meant that the
makeup crew never had to worry about
touching up or continuously checking on
the actor's teeth i'd say the most
difficult thing was just remembering all
of the moves in terms of the sword
fights no pirate movie is complete
without some badass sword fights the
cast of curse of the black pearl needed
to learn how to sword fight in order for
the fight scenes to look as stylized and
authentic as possible the cast was
taught by hollywood legend bob anderson
the military fort that nightly swan
faints off of in the film was an actual
practical set that was built on location
in palos verdes california though the
shot that shows her fainting and making
her impact into the ocean was shot in
the caribbean where a majority of the
filming took place
but thank you
you're welcome
not you we named the monkey jack
the scene where joffrey rushes captain
barbossa reveals to jack sparrow that
his pet monkey is also named jack with
the monkeys shooting a mockish smile
that was completely coincidental the
monkey smile wasn't actually planned but
performed the action at just the right
time to make for the memorable shot
the very first shot of the film that
features a pirate ship coming out of the
fog wasn't actually just one shot like
it appeared to be in fact the opening
shot was really five shots stitched
together to look like it was one take on
top of that despite this being one of
the very first scenes the crew shot it
wasn't finished until two days before
the film had its world premiere at
disneyland captain jack sparrow
well i didn't see your ship
captain while most of the film ships
were built from scratch the hms
interceptor wasn't instead a real ship
named lady washington was used for the
boat the crew had to repaint the entire
ship having to manually cut out ports
for the cannons and even change the
stern among other things in order to
design the pirates walking corpses the
crew used turkey jerky as an influence
to design the rotting flesh in order to
make the zombie pirates distinguishable
from each other the designers decided to
keep the actual eyes of each pirate
extra
that is without doubt the worst pirate i
have ever seen
the pirate genre had been dormant for
many years after the swashbuckling film
cutthroat island turned out to be a box
office flop writers ted elliott and
terry rossio had been wanting to make a
pirate themed movie with a supernatural
twist since the early 90s and decided to
pitch it to disney the mouse house was
certainly hesitant at first but decided
to make the script into an adaptation of
their popular theme park ride pirates of
the caribbean steven spielberg was at
one point attached to direct the film
before gore verbrinsky a year prior to
the release another film based on a
disney theme park attraction was
released in the form of the country
bears the film was an unmitigated
critical and financial disaster so much
so that disney head michael eisner
feared that the concept of a film based
on a theme park ride would no longer
work eisner tried to shut down the film
but furbinsky told his team to continue
to work on the film after eisner was
shown concept art for the film he
ultimately decided to let verbinski move
forward with the film you are without
doubt the worst pirate i've ever heard
of
but you have heard of me
before johnny depp was cast in the
iconic role of jack sparrow the creative
team actually had other actors in mind
the role was actually written with hugh
jackman in mind matthew mcconaughey
robert de niro jim carrey christopher
walken and carrie ellis were also looked
at to possibly take on the role of the
famed pirate eisner was initially not a
fan of depth's portrayal of jack sparrow
and was most confused about the
character's personality eisner was so
pessimistic that he thought depp's
eccentric performance would sink the
whole movie because audiences wouldn't
be able to get behind the character this
prediction turned out to be far from the
truth as depp was so universally praised
for his performance that he even earned
an oscar nomination for best actor much
like the casting of jack sparrow there
were plenty of actors in consideration
for the role of will turner with it
finally being narrowed down between
ledger and orlando bloom ultimately the
team went with bloom i saved your life
you saved mine with square depp claims
that the look mannerisms and partying
lifestyle of captain jack sparrow were
inspired by rolling stones guitarist
keith richards depp said that the main
reason he chose richards was because he
saw pirates as the rock stars of their
day and felt that richards perfectly
captured that aura kira knightley was
coming off the indie hit bend it like
beckham when she did the very first
pirates movie in fact she was only 17
years old at the time of filming nine
years younger than her love interest
orlando bloom because of her young age
nightly's mother had to accompany her
throughout the entire shoot nightly even
packed light fearing that she would be
fired early into the shoot and then got
offered it and here i am and i kind of
thought every single day that i was
going to be fired much of the film was
shot on location in the caribbean which
led to the cast and crew making their
way to set each day by boat after one
night of shooting on one of the main
islands a boat that was carrying kira
knightley and her mother hit a reef and
sank while no one on board was injured
the mother and daughter were stuck
waiting for several hours before they
were eventually rescued from then on
night shoots were instead filmed indoors
in a studio given the fact that i'm you
know playing a man who has a beard that
can play the organ pulling off the
iconic monstrosity that is davey jones
required an equally unique approach to
the visual effects industrial light and
magic's john knoll and his crew invented
an entirely new process for doing motion
capture which allowed actor bill nye to
perform the role on set with the rest of
the cast instead of by himself on an
empty blue screen sound stage noel and
his team were then able to build davey
jones and his tentacles completely off
of naihu's spectacular performance with
all his little quirks included and yet
not so fortunate is to find lander
the terrifying kraken wasn't initially
very scary for the actors on the set
probably because director gore verbinski
was standing in for it he's like you
know be afraid i'm a tentacle and you go
ah but eventually the legendary sea
monster was brought to life through a
mix of both practical and visual effects
in the scene where the cracking crushes
the ship the crew used a combination of
explosives and two huge pipes filled
with 30 thousand pounds of cement to
pull off the actual crushing and
afterward replace them with the cg
tentacles in the final cut and i don't
think it's cracking anyways
always heard it says breaking making a
movie in the caribbean is a bit tougher
than you might think the entire crew had
to get all their shots in order to
travel to the tropical film location i
hate shots i really do
i don't like needles the production
filmed in saint vincent the exumas the
grand bahamas and the tiny island of
dominica where they dealt with
torrential downpours and extreme heat
and humidity they also happened to be
shooting during one of the biggest
hurricane seasons on record choppy
waters forced them to shut down
countless times and at one point the
entire production had to evacuate in
order to avoid hurricane wilma i can't
help it if your standards are lacked you
smell funny jack
a lot goes into the look of a character
as interesting as jack sparrow jack's
gold teeth were bonded onto johnny
depp's real ones by a dentist before
filming began however some of the gold
teeth in the back are actually real
replacements a couple of these are mine
these ones towards the back
belong to me depp got the idea of having
different things in his hair from
rolling stone's guitarist keith richards
who was a huge inspiration for the
character another notable accessory
sparrow's striped sash from the first
movie had actually been lost so the
wardrobe department tracked down the
mountain villagers in turkey who wove
the original and had them churn out
another 100 yards of the sash
if you think jack's normal look is wild
wait till you see his get up as the god
of a cannibal tribe sparrow's clever
face paint design was an idea that gore
verbinski and the makeup team came up
with on the day of the scene however the
toe necklace was depp's idea and was
molded and sculpted from spare materials
on set sparrow's fluffy scepter was
actually a prop that was brought to set
by a visiting friend of depths who ended
up making two more for the production
you do know will taught me how to handle
a sword
having missed out on sword fights in the
first film kira knightley made up for it
by getting all the sword fights she
could handle in dead man's chest nightly
took to the sword very quickly never
failing to get the choreography on the
first try not only did she pretty much
do all elizabeth's sword fights herself
she also outdated her fellow castmates
and even earned the respect of the stunt
team
[Music]
easily one of the more creative sword
fights ever filmed the three-way duel
started on the disney lot where the
stunt team worked out the choreography
in a metal wheel fashioned with hidden
handles and handrails on set the wheel
was rigged to a truck and pulled through
the jungle with the actors harnessed
inside as awesome as it looked the
actors did not recommend the experience
when it came time for jack sparrow's
fateful showdown with the kraken some
elements were a little more real than
others specifically the monsters
spit
the spit in question was made of
concentrated sailing and blown out of a
bucket by an industrial sized fan onto
poor mr death after it had been tested
on his stand-in of course you can safely
assume it wasn't death's favorite gag
the foulness of just
living in it
everywhere all together wrong if there
was ever a scene that could outweird a
three-way sword fight in a rolling wheel
the bone cage sequence might have pulled
it off in order to get some authentic
performances the actors were strapped in
and literally rolled down a hill
swung from a crane
and at one point gore verbinski had them
carry the cage and run with it
themselves this is the last day in
dominica and gorge is trying to punish
us
that's what it is the actors may have
had a rough day but the dummies had it
even worse
when it comes to filming locations for
pirates the more obscure the better
verbinski and cinematographer darius
wolfski found tita gorge while looking
through a dominican tourist brochure and
thought it would be the perfect spot to
end the bone cage chase actors and crew
filmed while in freezing cold water that
was several feet deep and they had to
literally swim to location including the
67 year old actor who played cotton
david bailey the pirate life isn't easy
huh funny way to get to the office huh
who'd have guessed that the open ocean
would be so hard to shoot on while the
crew had particular trouble getting
boats to stay in place so gore verbinski
could get the shots he wanted you know
right when you line it up everything
moves everything else we're going to the
fishing boat constantly in flux with
four background boats and numerous
floating light rigs to keep in place in
moving water it was a big challenge to
get everything in frame one shoot night
went 17 hours without getting a single
take this again went to another level of
filmmaking for the filming of the
swordfight on a tiny little sandbar in
the middle of the ocean all the crew and
equipment still needed to be nearby that
meant putting the entire production on a
barge with a 20-minute boat ride to and
from set it was no cakewalk for the
actors either the sand there was super
wet thanks to the tide making it very
difficult to run and fight across the
beach for take after take after take
there's no one there
johnny depp stayed in character even
when he flubbed his lines and much like
jack sparrow dev was the source of
numerous comical moments on set at one
point he even forgot the name of the
notorious davy jones ship crocodile
machine or whatever it's called what's
the bloody thing called flying what
dutchman
but he was also very helpful to his
fellow cast seems like it's always a
good time when jack sparrows around
sorry
when it comes to a crew the size of a
small army you can never have enough
snacks actor jack davenport who played
the commodore james norrington was a bit
surprised to learn just how much of the
budget was going to the munchies i
remember saying to craft services chef
one day what is your budget for all this
he looked me square in the eye and said
essentially unlimited i was like what
does that mean he was like i don't know
2 million i was like for snacks and he
was like yeah safe to say no one went
hungry on this production
when the curse of the black pearl was
made there were no plans for any sequels
so while filming for her next movie
domino kira knightley chopped off her
actual hair for the part assuming she
wouldn't be reprising elizabeth swann
but when the sequels were announced
nightly had nothing for the pirates hair
and makeup team to work with so in dead
man's chest miss swan's long blocks are
in fact hair extensions
this is the super bowl of the motion
picture business right here the gigantic
ending battle between the black pearl
and dutchman is one of the biggest set
pieces in movie history they filmed the
sequence in a military hangar where they
constructed a massive set it required
920 feet of blue screen which is one of
the biggest in film history electrical
cables that stretched over eight stories
tall massive ships on gimbal systems to
rotate them and a water system to
simulate rain the pure mass of this set
is hard to comprehend and all of this
was designed and built in just three
months the visual effects side of this
battle was a massive undertaking of its
own as the sequence had over 320 vfx
shots which made up one third of all
visual effect shots for the movie
it required a massive amount of
computing time i mean it was just
mind-blowing the entirety of the
climactic fight between the black pearl
and dutchmen takes place in the rain
which meant the actors were constantly
getting soaked
on top of everything it's raining that's
a bad sign the set had a massive rain
system that dumped water at 50 000
gallons a minute captain barbosa actor
jeffrey rush said when his costume got
wet he weighed 45 pounds more
the last 10 weeks shooting of the movie
they had nothing left to shoot that
wasn't in torrential rain
for 10 weeks orlando bloom stated that
there were some days of shooting where
they would be wet the entire day it
doesn't look too comfortable behind the
scenes but it looks fantastic on screen
how wet could a man be
speaking of being soaked apparently
that's just par for the course when you
work on a movie about sailing the high
seas for the sequence when the black
pearl is flipped over the actors
actually filmed that scene underwater
they would all synchronize a breath hold
and then go under and hold onto a rail
for as long as they could until they
needed air they even filmed righty and
pintel tied to the mast underwater which
was a little nerve-wracking for the
actors not to worry though they had tons
of water safety experts on set just in
case of an emergency
it doesn't really feel like a good idea
to tie people up to a mast underwater
the dramatic and beautiful scene where
the endeavor ship gets torn to shreds
with beckett still on it is more
practical than you probably think all
the actors including beckett were filmed
separately from the exploding ship they
had a crew member counting on set so all
the actors could hit their marks at the
proper time
they then shot the same sequence but
this time with no actors they used
pyrotechnics and shot debris out of
cannons to simulate the ship blowing
apart motion controlled cameras were
used for both takes so the shots could
then be easily composited together for a
seamless sequence of beautiful
destruction lucky here boys
the lost
if you thought davey jones sword
fighting with jack sparrow on a high
beam up in the air was fake you'd be
half right the fight was shot
practically with johnny depp and a davy
jones stunt double performing the fight
on a small piece of the set the long
swooping shot following this fight
starts off 100 cgi including johnny depp
then transitions into the real johnny
depp and stunt double performance it's a
perfect example of practical elements
and cg working together
step lively
how do you create a scene with multiple
jack sparrows you have johnny depp do
the same scene over and over and over as
different versions of himself depp had
to rehearse the scene character by
character applying small nuances to each
version it was great challenge you know
he and director gore verbinski came up
with the individual quirks of each jack
variation they used a motion controlled
camera for each take repeating the
sequence for as many jacks were in the
shot they then overlaid the takes in
camera to give depp and the crew an idea
of what it would look like
when you see it's working it juices you
up you know in another multi-jack
sequence we see mini jack sparrows on
johnny depp's shoulders interacting with
his hair for this they build giant
dreadlocks that johnny depp did the
scene with they had one dread that was
suspended in the air with depth hanging
onto it we love that they decided to do
this practically as the visual of johnny
depp standing in giant dreads is worth
it alone
i wash my hands of this weirdness how do
they make the ships in the movie look so
real simple they build them for real
well simpler said than done david
jones's ship the dutchman was completely
built from scratch and was a real
sailboat with no motors it was inspired
by late 17th century design and
fittingly based on a dutch flute design
the design team used a urethane casting
a rubber-like substance to give the wood
an aged look on top of this all the
sculptures on the ship were created by
hand by their team of artists
there's so many man-hours involved in
this a combination of live-action ships
cgi and miniatures were used to bring
all the ships you see on screen to life
the scene where the black pearl and
dutchman surround the endeavor is a
perfect example of this technique the
black pearl was a real full-size ship
with some digital enhancements two
regular boats filled in for the other
ships and the wide shot of the endeavour
exploding was a miniature being blown up
ilm vfx supervisor john knoll stated the
importance of capturing a sequence in
camera first
my goal is to always start from some
live action so we've got some grounding
in reality that we can build from the
vast nothingness of davey jones's locker
is actually a real-life location they
shot the scene at the bonneville salt
flats of utah the director loved the
look of it and the vastness of the
landscape it rained a couple days before
shooting which almost ruined everything
but luckily it dried up enough to film
the full-size black pearl wasn't there
and was instead johnny depp interacting
with small parts of the ship one scene
they shot here included a blooper of
johnny depp hitting the ground pretty
hard
our intentions are strictly honorable
the opening sequence of the film sees
captain barbosa and elizabeth swann
visiting captain fang's dwelling to ask
for assistance when things go south our
main characters have swords thrown to
them through the floorboards jeffrey
rush and keira knightley had
difficulties catching said swords the
actors throwing them had some troubles
as well after a handful of mistakes they
finally got a clean take
did you know that when this movie was
made in 2007 it was the most expensive
movie ever made costing 300 million
dollars even more shocking 14 years
later it is still one of the most
expensive films ever made only coming in
behind avengers infinity war end game
age of ultron and fittingly one of its
sequels on stranger tides after
everything we've learned though we
understand why it costs so much
so we just call it square there another
delightfully practical set piece came
when the crew rocks the black pearl to
capsize the ship the actors filmed the
scene on a rotating ship deck they
actually ran against the tipping of the
boat catching and holding onto the
railing for the wide shots of the boat
actually flipping over a 24 foot long
miniature was used
i caught on captain t
keeper of the code jack sparrow's
character and look was influenced by
rock legend keith richards who appears
in atworld's end as jack's father
costume designer penny rose wanted his
character's costume to be more elaborate
and aristocratic than jack sparrow's
more rough and weathered outfit they had
trouble getting enough materials to make
multiples of the costume but eventually
we're able to secure the necessary
supplies and give the character a unique
style
it's not just about living forever
jackie calypso turning into hundreds of
crabs is obviously a cgi effect but
would you have guessed that they
actually filmed practical elements of
this scene for the vfx team to work with
the crew used blue clay balls to fill in
for the crabs and dropped three large
nets filled with them onto the deck of
the black pearl it only took about five
seconds for all the balls to drop but
we're sure the cleanup took much longer
working with some of the greatest actors
in the world is terribly exciting
director rob marshall preferred shooting
on location as much as possible and this
decision almost cost him his life while
shooting in the jungles of hawaii
marshall got a real taste of the
mercilessness of the wild
mid-conversation with johnny depp and
penelope cruz he slipped while standing
on a cliff thanks to his quick reflexes
he managed to grab a vine just before
taking a dive this didn't deter him
though as he believes you are having an
adventure while you're making one the
team agreed it was better to recreate
the set in studio not just because of
this but because of the dangers
presented by the surf
actress penelope cruz was pregnant
during the filming there she was you
know fencing and fighting and
amazing and pregnancy she had two months
of training leading up to filming but
ultimately couldn't do everything she
had to make choices for the safety of
her and her future child and so her
sister monica was brought in to be her
double for some of the scenes monica is
an actress and dancer in spain and is
very good with swords a perfect choice
to fill in for some of the fight scenes
but also to hide that baby bump
and then i did
a lot of it but i always saved nothing
nothing dangerous one of the many
reasons on stranger tides was so
expensive to film comes down to the
props that were designed for the movie
more than a dozen washed up mermaids
each in different stages of decay were
created over the course of seven weeks
one incredibly detailed mermaid was
casted of silicone to give it a whale
blubbery texture for when barbosa kicks
it
mermaid
give up this madness now it's kind of a
tragedy how much of it is covered with
sand in the film because the detail in
the design is absolutely incredible
did everyone see that because i will not
be doing it again pirates of the
caribbean on stranger tides is the most
expensive movie ever made holding the
record even 10 years later with a budget
of roughly
379 million it came in at well over 400
million that makes it more expensive
than the avengers films and avatar
johnny depp is one of the reasons for
the expensive budget he made a whopping
55 million for the film and admits he
was overpaid
too much
but says he's keeping the money because
it isn't for him it's for his kids
movies filmed at sea are often the most
expensive which is why all of the
pirates of the caribbean movies cost so
much we had beautiful actresses playing
the mermaids mermaids were a huge part
of on stranger tides and director rob
marshall was very specific about how he
wanted them to look while disney gave
the team the go-ahead to make them look
super scary marshall decided to dial
that back and still keep the beautiful
qualities about the actresses in an
attempt to create never-before-seen
mermaids the team landed on a design
that included jellyfish-like tendrils a
lot of references were used from sea
life to human skin they even bought some
fish at the fish market for their
research
i'm jack sparrow the one and only and i
am in london
this film is the first in the series to
be shot entirely in 3d a choice by
director rob marshall who says the crew
felt like pioneers we were taking 3d
equipment into these remote locations
where you have the possibility of one of
two cameras breaking which they did more
than once that's an entrance
filming in 3d in temperamental
environments like jungles caves
waterfalls ships and cliffs can really
add to the number of problems you run
into marshall believes that to use 3d
you have to be telling a story in a
world that people are going to want to
enter so he avoided green screens as
much as possible putting actual ships in
tiny bottles is the kind of ingenuity
we've come to expect from the franchise
the team designed the ships to look like
they did when they were first captured
stormy cg water special lighting
lightning and more was added to make the
bottle containing the black pearl look
as if it had been captured in a storm
the team even went so far as to include
a shot of jack the monkey we named the
monkey jack while one of the shots was
the real capuchin other shots were just
cg let's take everybody up thank you
filming a movie about pirates you're
going to run into a lot of mishaps with
swords our favorite being between kevin
mcnally and johnny depp sorry my sword
nearly went up johnny's nose which
wouldn't be good
while it sounds innocent enough these
mistakes can often be quite dangerous
but luckily no one was hurt and we got
great bloopers like depp trying again
and again and again to take cruz's hat
off with his sword i think this takes
going very well don't you
[Laughter]
in order for penelope cruz to do such a
perfect imitation of depp's character
the whole thing was staged like dance
choreography to keep her identity a
secret involved an intricate costume
carefully planned shots low lighting and
a ton of cg
while the two of them battle it out on
the rafters they're strung up in
complicated rigs to remove all the wires
the editors replace the roof and cg and
created the cg barrels you can see in
the background many girls dream of being
a mermaid and the women casted to play
them in on stranger tides were thrilled
to be there being evil an evil mermaid
but it's gonna be awesome actual olympic
athletes were hired for some of the
sequences while actors took on the
speaking parts and the stunt doubles
took on some of the more dangerous work
there'll be mermaids upon us within the
hour you mark my words animals have to
go through months of training to perform
simple tasks but training is always fun
when there's food around for chiquita
the monkey a lot of time grapes bananas
and pudding goes into training while the
pig's goal was simple to escape the
clutches of kevin mcnally in a game of
tug-of-war pigs they never work with
them
teaching an animal to escape sounds like
a pretty backwards pet trick to us it's
160 pounds of very low good traction the
scene where queen anne's revenge is
chasing the mermaids is pretty much all
done with cg the ship the fire the water
and the mermaids are not real that
leaves us wondering what is funny enough
queen anne's revenge is the first ship
in the series that's based on an actual
pirate ship so at least we know one
thing is real
you can't have your cake and eat it too
unless of course your captain jack
sparrow an incredibly complicated
sequence is played out in the film when
jack goes after a cream puff that gets
stuck to a chandelier unfortunately for
johnny depp it's just cg
the chandelier however was real and was
controlled by giant pulleys and motors
that had to support the weight of depp
the sequence where queen anne's revenge
comes to life and fights back against
the crew had incredibly intricate
choreography in place
my favorite part of the day hanging on a
line for hours
a lot had to come together in order for
this scene to work from pyrotechnics to
swordfights and half the cast fighting
back against magical ropes some of which
were cgi it made for quite the shot
filming in the port of los angeles on
the hms providence was an exciting
adventure for the cast and crew because
it was actually fully functional as a
ship and required a sailing crew a fully
cg version of the ship was also designed
for when the mermaids tear it apart what
we're wondering is how much of the cast
got seasick while filming on the ship
today we are filming parts of the
caribbean
dead men tell no tale
follow me hi is your bank running well
you better go catch it
that was not part of the plan what fun
is cgi when you've got a team that can
put together a production like this
we've got a tractor at the core of that
bank which was built by the art
department and of course this stampede
of horses oh yeah that bank tractor
driver couldn't see where he was going
coordination within all the departments
was key here did we mention this was at
the top of filming off to the race as we
go
everybody clear because the wall is
coming down
[Music]
yeah we were serious
not a shortcut was taken to pull off
stunts of this magnitude these sets
managed to cause chaos in more ways than
one though
tell me
step aside baby shark it's time for
ghost sharks how broken you can make
something look and still keep it
threatening we've never really thought
about it but the pirates team was hard
at work building fully realized versions
of the sharks and then going in
digitally to really ghostify them we're
talking broken jaws flies slime the goal
was for these sharks to look really
menacing
now if we were to run into these in the
wild we'd definitely run the other way
so mission accomplished team
chuck
hey salazar need some moisturizer they
look like they've been blown up the idea
of cracked earth quickly inspired
salazar and his crew's look one that
meant a whole lot of time was being
spent in the makeup chair this is all
prosthetics
we're talking three three and a half
hours every single time it took me a
little while to adjust to the time frame
patience was key though not everyone had
the full treatment done this is all done
with stencils and transfers there aren't
enough hours in a day to do it all how
much of his head is missing exactly and
is he okay they were bringing this idea
of the
face with a hole in it
which i it was hard for me to imagine
while he did have incredible prosthetics
the salazar actor still got the cgi
treatment to make so much of his skull
go bye-bye
it was either cracked earth makeup or
blue for javier perfect for achieving
that uh
let's call it a ghostly aesthetic
new director new dop new cast members
it's been a very rewarding one change
can be tough but bringing in new
directors was welcomed with open arms
directors are very young and very
energetic they move the camera a lot
they use a lot of drones bringing in a
new perspective for the fifth film in
the franchise turned out to be a pretty
special experience
they managed to brilliantly keep within
the pirate genre while bringing a bit of
a different look to the screen i felt it
was like it's a real moment every day on
this on this shoot is that dirt or
makeup or both becoming gibbs was a far
from glamorous process tan sunburn and
then
muck
some rubbish [ __ ] but it was definitely
creative since he had to get a kind of
grimy dirty look why waste fancy makeup
when you can go with the best source of
all we get a little mud from the car
park
and we rub it in like that see
and even that could be too fancy at
times and we're rationing the mud from
the car park this morning get me some
more mud from the car park something
looks different but the same he really
isn't gibbs without the signature mutton
chops which happened to have been grown
by kevin mcnally himself for the first
four movies but for dead men tell no
tales i have time to grow them this time
the best part about prosthetic mutton
chops they didn't have as much gray hair
as mcnally really does
is gunk ever really convenient
the salazar actor was initially told the
gunk he was going to use would taste
like chocolate but the reality wasn't so
sweet have the air dove right in though
they were supposed to put it on the
teeth i said give me that so i drunk it
but then it all came pouring out of his
mouth again disgust was a real strong
vibe that day better watch out where
you're going or you'll land somewhere
you shouldn't that was not comfortable
at all it was early days in the filming
process and one of this pair's first
scenes together and kaya made a bit of a
misstep the director thought it would be
funny to have her step on her co-star's
crotch but not for real of course
unfortunately they missed the mark on
this one i accidentally stood a new
crotch
and a final sprint to the finish line it
had been such a tough shoot and so long
and everyone's so tired no better way to
wrap up than shooting with high stakes
we had a scene where
we could only do it once this scene
turned out to be one of the best ways to
finish the experience in a setting that
was more like a family vacation than a
movie set it's a good thing everything
went off without a hitch since that
beach couldn't be reset so easily after
the cast ran through like we're running
towards the finish line they didn't have
to be in the sea to be underwater we
have a sequence under the sea yes in
around two or three months the crew
built this incredible environment on dry
land we were tasked with the
job of trying to create an underwater
environment every single detail we see
was built from scratch from the coral to
the creatures to the sea floor a lot of
coral of texture very very wet having
such a detailed and rich environment
made it very easy for the actors to feel
like they really were underwater are we
under water or is it just special
effects two weeks of that you get a
little cuckoo but uh
it looks good in the movie yeah no
kidding we'd be asking that if we saw
lights and shadows that so convincingly
made it feel like we were in the bottom
of the sea too we ended up with a very
simple
system of just old-fashioned water
tricks
a giant lighting rig and small pools of
water that were hung up along the
ceiling and connected with other lights
that could be manipulated while shooting
made all of this possible who needs cg
when you've got blinking lights and
perfectly rippled water
number 14. land hoe
not just yet though there is some pirate
business to take care of of course there
were many days on set spent in the water
both on huge rigs and smaller dinghies
many of which were made just for the
movie by the way once you get into the
pirates mode anything can happen the
view is bliss but getting changed out at
sea is hardly comfortable a price worth
paying though for a movie like this
sometimes it's easy as walking it looks
epic to film but take after take of
continuously being wet in mocap suits no
less well it doesn't make for the
easiest day on set
walking in this case not so chill but of
course the pirate's team makes it work
surprisingly there were no yellow
submarines on set enough said he's one
of the greatest musicians songwriters
performers paul mccartney happens to be
a close pal of johnny depps and came on
board as a favor even though he was
surprised to be asked at all it's a
whole new pirate
by the looks of depp's delighted face
mccartney delivered
oh maggie maggie may they have taken
their way
yeah i'm loving him they look good but
they are far from practical cayo
scotlario was whipping out stunts on set
all while wearing 17 layers including a
tight corset i'm very much a jeans and
t-shirt girl so i was quite nervous
about all of that there were also plenty
of heels on set but not just for the
women take note brenton thwaites was
sporting them in not so ideal conditions
i found the high heels on the boats to
be pretty challenging toss those heels
overboard
sorry we're here for the pirates of the
caribbean content whoa yep this is it no
solo acoustic guitar tracks here dead
men tell no tales went all out recording
the orchestrations and incidental music
live for the film it really does take a
village and this one can certainly play
listen to that string section
and next up we'll be serenaded by jack
sparrow himself when he wasn't busy jack
sparrowing johnny depp could be found
tucked away spending some quality time
with his guitar it's nice to see that
kind of quiet side to him i think
between depp and that orchestra this
team was set for tunes how many ships
does it take to make a pirates of the
caribbean movie for dead men tell no
tales there were a whopping 13 ships
built including one that measured a
massive hundred and sixty feet long
and these were no basic boats see how
every detail tiny detail of the of the
construction of the set is so well taken
care of period speak is tricky business
kevin mcnally has been doing the pirates
gig from the very beginning and if
something didn't sound right he was
gonna know it his accurate year came in
very handy for kaia she was still
learning the ropes we were discussing in
line i think i say okay
and he pulled up and he said nope that
is not historically accurate sticklers
for detail make pirates of the caribbean
the legendary franchise it is
some takes may have been ruined but it
doesn't mean they weren't fun when takes
went sour it wasn't necessarily because
an actor messed up in this case it's
because this pirate was a bit too good
at his job well actually he didn't the
actors around him did like i like myself
at least they all got a good laugh
number 23. no matter which costume it
was you can be sure it was detailed to
the max there's two different costumes
there's a clean version and then this
one is what we call the ghosted version
from the fine silver embroidery to the
individually attached buttons the
character in this costume speaks volumes
number 24 the production schedule got
thrown for a loop because the one and
only jack sparrow was so often late it
was such a problem that the team
actually had a production assistant
literally staking outside of depp's
house in a car waiting to see when the
actor woke up just so the production
could get moving filming was then
further delayed by an offset hand injury
that put depp out of commission where so
much magic happened working on
whitsunday islands is particularly
special because they happen to be sacred
lands before the crew began filming
representatives from the ungaro people
performed a traditional smoking ceremony
to bring good spirits to the team and
production